apparently there's a new friend's face
app let's check it out joey how you
doing
oh
looks good with an earring
or two hello lute my little lisa cooge
[Music]
i have no idea we're calling this the
one where courtney cox transforms into
her friend's co-stars well kind of i am
the energy train and you are on board
i just remember it being such an amazing
time the actress who played monica
geller on the iconic series had some fun
testing out the new friends filter on
instagram first up ross and joey hi
really i don't even look anything like
shimmer joey how you doing
oh
it looks good with an earring
or two how you doing
next court has a little difficulty
figuring out if the face is monica's or
rachel's who's played by her good pal
jennifer aniston oh hello
who was that
is that monaco
i'm not sure
rachel
i have no idea it's one of the worst
apps i've ever seen but okay
is that me no i think my eyebrows are a
little different
uh rachel
i don't buy it this is the worst mouth
of anyone so it's not jennifer or
rachel because she's got a gorgeous
mouth and i have no is this me but i
take a shower
she leaves me little notes on the mirror
yeah i do i i do do that
and now you have to
leave and i have to live with a boy
as for courtney's on-screen hubby
chandler played by matthew perry well
the result is equally bizarre wow
chandler has rosacea
oh chandler
what is chandler bing's job it's um it
has something to do with trans funding
oh oh it's a transplant trans monster
that's not even a word
this face filter fun comes just weeks
after courtney admitted her time on
friends is a little fuzzy i see it on tv
sometime tonight right i stop and go
oh my god i don't remember this at all
that is so funny is that right yeah it
doesn't matter what generation is
watching it it's just it holds up people
can relate to every character i don't
care how big the cell phone is the
computer you can't lift
life is that way and that and you know
if you have a friend group which is your
family but if there's one thing the
scream star does remember it's the
amazing bond she had with her cast and
crew i mean the start was just these
people getting to know each other and
becoming friends and um
i just remember it being such an amazing
time we had such great writers
the whole thing was the best experience
that i could possibly imagine i felt
very lucky to have been a part of that
show
and everything kind of seems to pale in
comparison whenever i read comedies
almost like you can't compare i just we
were really lucky and there are
just the friendships the chemistry
like i said writers the producers the
whole thing
[Music]
you